Mario jumped onto the video game scene
over 40 years ago but there was so much
more to learn about everyone's favorite
plumber before you head to the theaters
for his Next Big Adventure everyone
knows who Mario is and that's no
accident Nintendo has meticulously
created one of Gaming's biggest
franchises going all the way back to
their Flagship character's debut
appearance in 1981's Donkey Kong arcade
game this Series has a long and proud
history as one of the most consistent
entertaining fun and Fresh franchises in
all of gaming that constantly pushes the
boundaries of the genre that's exactly
why this newest film adaptation is so
highly anticipated by fans beginning
with 1983's Mario Brothers arcade game
Nintendo transitioned the franchise into
Home Entertainment Systems in 1985 with
the release of Super Mario Brothers on
the NES players enjoyed controlling both
Mario and Luigi as a Traverse the
Mushroom Kingdom in search of Princess
Peach this core game Loop continued into
later installments on home consoles and
handhelds before May taking the leap to
3D
Mario
hello
that's gaming technology advanced so too
did the complexity of games being
released on each successive console with
the release of 1996's Super Mario 64 new
features continued to be added to make
each Mario Adventure more interesting
the franchise remains an essential piece
of gaming history only time will tell
which aspects of this Prestige franchise
will show up in the upcoming movie
originally Mario was supposed to jump
into the big screen on December 21st
2022 sadly for fans hoping to spend the
holiday season with Luigi Bowser and
Princess Peach their release date was
pushed back to 2023. fortunately we
won't have to wait much longer to see
Mario's adventures in the Mushroom
Kingdom the Super Mario Brothers movie
has a new release date of April 5th 2023
we're expecting the movie to make quite
a bit of cash during its box office run
as it won't have any animated
competition trying to draw similar
crowds as for Nintendo's homeland of
Japan the film will open on April 28th
just a few weeks later
Universal and illumination spared no
expense when it comes to Casting the
Super Mario Brothers movie voicing Mario
is none other than Star-Lord himself
Chris Pratt Charlie Day of It's Always
Sunny in Philadelphia joins him as
Mario's brother Luigi Anya Taylor joy of
the Queen's gambits and the menu plays
Princess Peach we can also expect to
hear the scarier than usual tones of
Jack Black as antagonist Bowser in
supporting roles Keegan Michael Key
portrays toad Seth Rogen steps in as
Donkey Kong and Fred Armisen is the
voice of crunky Kong the announcement
also knows that Charles martinet whose
voice Mario and other notable characters
in the video games since the 90s will
have surprise cameos the Super Mario
Brothers movie is the result of two
powerful forces coming together Nintendo
and illumination and that collaborative
Dynamic is represented in the film's
producers on one side you've got Chris
maladandri the producer behind the
Despicable Me and sing franchises on the
other side you've got Shigeru Miyamoto
the genius who created Mario as well as
characters like Donkey Kong Link and
Zelda together they bring their
animation and video game knowledge to
the big screen as for who's directing
the Super Mario Brothers movie recruited
two figures who are quite Adept at
handling animated projects Aaron Horvath
and Michael jelanick the filmmakers
behind Teen Titans go to the movies Helm
the picture they're working from a
script pens by Matthew Fogle who
previously wrote The Lego Movie to the
second part and minions the rise of Gru
as you might expect a Super Mario
Brothers movie got the standard rating
for Family Fare PG it perfectly lines up
with illuminations other offerings like
Despicable Me and the secret life of
pets according to the classification and
ratings administration's website the
movie has earned its PG rating for
action and Mild violence we expect the
violence to be incredibly mild anyone
familiar with the games knows Mario's
propensity for ditching out pain only
extends to jumping on Goombas or
occasionally throwing Fireballs at a
Koopa Trooper even the trailers show
that the action will be light-hearted
and comical as depicted when Donkey Kong
hilarious heat slaps our favorite
plumber around or when a penguin Army
assaults Bowser with snowballs and the
Cooper comeback returns a favor by
magically tossing them aside Mario is
one of the most popular video game
characters in history and the Super
Mario Brothers franchise has always been
a fundamental part of gaming culture as
a result because of this popularity it
should come as no surprise that this
isn't first time Mario has greater
Silver Screen since his debut appearance
in 1981. Nintendo has tried multiple
times to turn Mario into a multimedia
character Beyond just video games but
they've never been particularly
successful in the past the first time
Mario and friends ever appeared in a
feature film was in a 1986 animated
Adventure picture named Super Mario
Brothers the great mission to rescue
Princess Peach since Mario had already
achieve significant popularity in his
home country of Japan producers saw an
opportunity to make a cheap 60-minute
anime based around Mario and Luigi's
usual goal of rescuing Princess Peach
from Bowser another more Infamous big
screen adaptation was in the 1993
live-action film Super Mario Brothers
starring Bob Hoskins as Mario and John
Leguizamo as Luigi the movie was a total
flop currently holding an abysmal 29
rating on Rotten Tomatoes
[Music]
the people who made the Super Mario
Brothers movies certainly know their
Mario history as the film is filled with
all sorts of Easter eggs and Throwbacks
for fans for example both the film's
official trailer and a character poster
show our heroes driving down the Rainbow
Road a thoroughfare instantly
recognizable to Mario Kart fans Peach
can even be seen riding a motorcycle
Pango Mars for her outfit design that
goes all the way back to Mario Kart Wii
expecto marches to plenty of other
worlds as well from Luigi's Mansion to
the original Super Mario Brothers on top
of that it looks like our titular
plumber Dons quite a few super suits
throughout his Adventure in a teaser for
the film we witnessed Mario's Showdown
with Donkey Kong where he puts on a
literal catsuit turning him into cap
Mario from Super Mario 3D World in the
trailer we also see him soaring around
the natsanuki suit which hails from
Super Mario Bros 3. we also know that
quite a few classic Mario baddies appear
in the movie from the hammer brothers
and the Sorcerer comic it's a Goombas
bombs piranha plants buzzy beetles and
shy guys we also suspect that elements
from Mario's Big Space Bound Adventures
might come into play some shots of
upcoming Mario themes McDonald's toys
revealed Aluma an adorable star-like
creature from Super Mario Galaxy of
course there are even references to
Unique Mario properties in the marketing
during the Super Bowl fans were treated
to a Mario Brothers promo that acted as
a commercial for Mario and Luigi's
Plumbing Service in the mock
advertisement we're treated to the same
Mario rap that's also the incredibly
cheesy theme of the Super Mario Brothers
Super Show a series that would open each
episode with that plumbing hip-hop beat
Mario is a character has completely
transcended the video game franchise
that created him by becoming a true
Bonafide pop culture icon everyone's
favorite plumber is a universally
recognized symbol of Nintendo and gaming
in general thanks to his unique place as
both a leading character and a corporate
mascot Mario is an essential part of
Nintendo's business strategy since the
Super Mario games make millions of
dollars with each release but this
character also has staying power with
everyone according to Guinness World
Records Mario is one of the biggest and
most instantly recognized video game
characters ever made by a huge margin he
was officially named the second most
recognizable video game character in
2009 only getting beat out by Pac-Man by
one percent according to a statement by
Mario's Creator Shigeru Miyamoto during
an official briefing his iconic
character even has notable comparisons
to Disney's Mickey Mouse Miyamoto said I
felt bad that Mickey Mouse would have
been hugely popular among fans including
myself for 60 years at that point was
even being compared to Mario who had
just been around for a few years back
then as anyone with an internet
connection can tell you it can get
pretty heated online when fans discuss
her obsessions over social media while
you might think that the fan base for
Nintendo's Flagship franchise would be
on the friendlier side since the source
material is so colorful you'd be
surprised with the release of the Super
Mario Brothers trailer fans have gone on
record to voice their opinions both
positive and negative about the new
footage while the consensus seems to
lean towards fans loving the character
designs humor and storytelling of the
trailer they also generally are
installed on Nintendo's choice of
leading man as mentioned Mario is voiced
by Chris Pratt who seems to be using his
regular voice to play the character
rather than imitating Mario's iconic
Italian accent this was noted by many
fans on Twitter who commented that The
Supporting Cast featuring Charlie Day
Anya Taylor joy and Jack Black will do
the heavy lifting for this film no
pressure we're entering the Golden Age
of video game adaptations with slum
dunks like Sonic the Hedgehog and HBO's
The Last of Us proving that the curse of
bad movies based on games can be broken
that being said there's a reason people
thought that curse existed in the first
place since so many terrible adaptations
have been made over the years the Super
Mario Brothers movie has the potential
to be the next example of a video game
movie done right but only if the
filmmakers learned from previous
mistakes video game movies have a
reputation for being cheap cash-ins of
popular gaming franchises made hastily
under little regard for their Source
material one of the worst examples of
this has to be the Resident Evil films
which forsake everything good about
Capcom survival horror series by
presenting big over-the-top spectacles
and not much more 2002's Resident Evil
has only a 35 rating on Rotten Tomatoes
but each successive entry gets even
worse reviews across the board Mortal
Kombat is another arcade-based franchise
that has suffered from lackluster
adaptations since the first movie in
1995. despite enjoying a cult following
these days with the star power behind
the upcoming Mario movie it's unlikely
this adaptation would join the pantheon
of bad video game flicks like with most
major franchise films today there's
potential for countless spin-offs if the
Super Mario Brothers movie does well at
the box office in a 2021 interview with
Fast Company Nintendo's Global president
shuntaro Furukawa said that the powers
of B have no intention of rushing things
unless they're certain there's a market
for it he said animation in general is
something that we are looking into and
not just this franchise one of the big
movies that could come down the pipeline
if the Super Mario Brothers movie is
successful is a standalone film
dedicated to Donkey Kong the Beloved
gorilla character voiced by Seth Rogen
in this upcoming adaptation according to
Giant freaking robots the film is
already in development illumination but
the details on his potential plots
remain thin it's likely however that
many of the characters introduce in the
Super Mario Brothers movie will make
appearances in this proposed Donkey Kong
solo feature another spin-off we can
expect in year succumb is the Luigi's
Mansion movie based on a series of
action-adventure games Luigi's voice act
dead Charlie Day expressed interest in
the project in an interview with
comicbook.com saying yeah my son was
just playing Luigi's Mansion the other
day on his switch look I'm thrilled to
get the opportunity I grew up playing
Super Mario Brothers as did everyone I
know so we'll see it's like anything
else life I'll go if I'm invited
foreign
[Music]